un jour peut-être une fois surtout quand
je tombe je vais appeler les pompiers au
cas où faire des radios mais je suis là
au sénat dont je veux sauter la rentrée
pas trop trop bas j'avais peur de même
si c'est si on les genres pourquoi
j'avais peur de m'éclater quoi
[Musique]
je cassé le col du fémur
quand j'avais 10 11 ans alors que
normalement c'est plus les personnes
âgées qui ont besoin des problèmes et la
manière dont je me suis cassé c'est plus
que je suis tombé devant moi et je me
suis cassé le fémur donc c'est un peu
c'est un peu par rapport à un petit
radar qui s'est développée pour trouver
les trucs dont je ça par exemple les
deux leaders un peu bizarre comme ça je
veux pas trop gâché un peu en voie de
son be quand je marche la nuit et tout
ça peut m'arriver de nous faire mal sur
ça donc je fais attention
j'ai un peu suivi des mots clés au
collège surtout les premières années et
c'est un sujet du coût qui me tient un
peu à coeur que le harcèlement ce qu'on
garde ça tout ça mais du coup je vois je
joue aux vidéos forcément c'est un peu
plus à ce moment là pour pour un peu
échappé même qui ensuite ça allait mieux
c'est un peu aussi un point de départ
c'est que j'ai beaucoup sécher jeux
vidéo parce que eh bien peut-être monde
et si j'étais un peu dans ma bulle
dans ma bulle c'est là que je faisais
mais quand je rentrais joue à lol il
faisait savoir je jouais pas trop trop
non plus et du coup mes potes c'était
mes potes de jeu mais au final j'ai pu
tisser des liens avec eux et j'ai
rarement été aussi un peu plus adulte et
du couffo et s'aggravent poule ce que je
vais mettre les jeux vidéo c'était que
ce qui est juste anonyme est juste un
pseudo au début je jouais si on a donné
de l'assurance fera mesure de commencer
un gravira tous les échelons
je ne suis pas confiance en moi et j'ai
pu parler plus librement
je pense souvent alors même que le
cheval soit enfin je me brosse les dents
ça dans quelques
je pensais à 10 trajets des personnages
pouvaient jouer donc là c'est la salle
on s'entraîne mais katsuyuki là ils ont
fait notre entraînement ici
moi j'ai tout ici c'est un bon
et on à l'autre de colchicine le bon
dieu la patrie je peux lancer une partie
en classe et un classement européen
en ce moment je suis en 70 80 je crois
ne voulait pas que j'étais dans le top 5
je fais beaucoup de partis pour gta
seront là que tu t'entraînes combien
d'heures par jour où je ça dépend des
jours mais disons que ces 5 ans minimum
avec une équipe au jeu 5 leur ensemble
ont beau et des fois je rajoute une deux
ou trois heures de jeu en ce moment du
coup il ya un joueur atypique parce que
c'est c'est une pépite
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que tout
coule c'est c'est le futur de league of
legends
très clairement dans les prochaines
années il va briller en est le sait au
plus haut niveau européen
je suis pro depuis deux ans maintenant
l'année dernière j'ai gagné deux fois la
nfl police française et cette année j'ai
pas gagné mais j'ai reçu le trophée de
meilleur joueur de la ligue
mon objectif qu'un petit meneur lol ça
se fait participer aux championnats du
monde et de gagner mais bon pour arriver
là faut toutefois encore quelques années
je m'en rapproche pour moi rien est
impossible
[Musique]